on the issue of parenting i see this
making the cut
nice title by the way
younger men seek vasectomies in the wake
of roe v wade ruling now you see why the
title is fancy there you go
let's read a little younger men of the
big apple new york
shocking
shocking for this to happen in new york
and across the country but it's they're
using the big apple for a reason
are scrambling to book appointments to
get vasectomies in the wake of last
week's supreme court decision to
overturn roe v wade
urologists and prospective patients told
the post then there's a doctor here with
a really long name i'm going to say
wrong dr alex something director of
urology at new york urology specialist
in midtown manhattan estimated that
calls about vasectomy procedures have
soared by more than 500 percent this
week 500 that's not a small number
if they're at a point where they don't
plan on having children and have been
relying on other methods they can
certainly drive them toward this could
certainly drive them toward vasectomy
okay this is the best part even with new
york officials pledging that abortion
will still be legal in the empire state
not everyone understands that
to someone who might not understand the
legal system it sounds like the supreme
court has banned abortion so obviously
we know first and foremost let's talk
about the dumb i hate when the dumb
hurts but sometimes it hurts and you
have to say it
no one has banned abortion
what they did again returned it to the
states nothing is going to happen to
abortion in new york
nothing
if anything maybe they'll expand it just
to be a little extra spiteful
nothing's going to happen to abortion in
california either
nothing is going to happen because they
didn't ban it
they gave it back to the states it's
called the 10th amendment people should
read up on it sometime not saying you
have it but maybe that guy in the photo
before he snip snip snips might want to
know what the real facts are
this is my favorite part of the article
though i can't
the example they use they're talking
about young guys right and this is
happening apparently a trend among young
men but the example they use
is dj edgerton who's 53.
okay
i nearly honestly i nearly passed out
from the laughter reading this for many
reasons we need to read it together and
there are many reasons why dj edderton
53 who's single
he splits his time between manhattan
newport rhode island and sarasota
florida isn't convinced abortion rights
are secure in new york the dumb hurts
and was among those prompted by the
scotus decision to call this doctor's
office about getting snipped
that word snipped sounds it's aggressive
just gonna say
edgerton who founded a design tech firm
said his sisters and two daughters have
been busting my balls pun intended
obviously well done i'll give him some
points on the humor during the last few
years to get a vasectomy
this is what he says
it's a tragedy that this right has been
taken away from women again it hasn't
correction and i think the convenience
of that is an option the convenience of
it
as an option
no longer being there especially that i
live in florida half the year
makes this a more potent solution now
first of all the fact that these words
came out of a 53 year old man
i don't know what to say it's like an
overgrown baby talking literally by age
of 53 you haven't figured out there are
things you can do to prevent yourself
from having a baby there are steps you
can take
first of all he's just a 53 year old man
he's not 20 he's 53 years old and this
is by the way an epidemic among new york
city guys sorry if you're watching from
new york city and you take issue with
this but there's an epidemic of over
grown man babies
in new york this is this did not shock
me at all for a grown-ass man in new
york to say this grotesque men in texas
harder to find one that would say this
can't imagine why let's think about the
differences hmm
what i what bothers me about this again
you can get vasectomy if you want i
don't care what you do it's your body
it's not mine
i'm not telling you what to do what
bothers me about this is the way that a
grown man talks about abortion
like it's like again we're not talking
about a baby it's not that serious just
like convenient options so i get to be
responsible
i get to just bounce from coast to coast
and i know that if i'm irresponsible
i'll just have it'll just be covered
someone will just go in and get an
abortion end of story
that type of like laxity with which
people talk about it
where they're just like oh whatever
that's what's wrong with the whole
conversation
that is what's wrong with the whole
conversation
you know what what's his name dj every
time i say dj i think of dj tanner from
full house if you do too that's a sign
that you're old just fyi tyler's not
thinking about dj tanner from full house
when i say dj are you tyler no no
because tyler's 20-something and i'm 75.
you're thinking about some guy with
white spiky hair there you go frosted
tips this is the difference between him
and i but if you're a big gold chain at
53 years old if you're home and when i
said dj you thought dj tanner you and i
i see you i feel seen not gonna lie but
dj here 53 grown ass man
in name only apparently
maybe
maybe by 53 you would realize
that you should be less promiscuous
maybe you should reserve these
encounters for people that actually
matter
for intimacy for relationships where if
somebody did get pregnant that that
would be a step you'd want to take with
them
maybe you could wrap it up dj
there you go
there are things you can do and i'm not
saying they're full proof but that's why
you should only be engaging in behavior
with people where if something happens
you're like you know what i welcome that
let's start a family
sex should be taken seriously
this is a note for everybody young out
there too sex should be taken seriously
it's not taken seriously anymore it's a
big problem we're going to get to that
at the end by the way
but i just can't believe and people say
you know when when stuff comes up about
new york sometimes with new york guys i
always have it's so fun i have a lot of
male friends
some of them live in the south texas in
particular i love the guys text they're
like that can't be really how guys in
new york and i'm like this this is just
an average guy your average 50 something
year old in new york acts like he's you
know 28
and the brain has not evolved and
there's a lot of just oh it'll be you
know it's an easy fix whatever
nothing is serious
sex should be serious if dj hasn't
figured that out by 53 i don't know who
can help him maybe his sisters can have
a conversation with him i don't know if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]